stacy's with us in houston hi stacy
welcome to the dave ramsey show hi
hello hey what's up thank you for taking
my call um
uh basically i was just uh curious you
recommend that your
mortgage not be more than 25 percent of
your take home
and uh just wondering that's um the case
with me it's actually more um 25 for us
and i was wondering does that change the
approach
to your monthly bill paying and paying
down debt um
or just basically making more cutbacks i
just wondered what you would
suggest well you got less money
because it's going to the house that's
the approach i mean
by the time you pay your house payment
there's not much money left so what
percentage of your take-home pay is your
house payment
uh well take-home was five thousand and
the mortgage is roughly
two thousand nineteen hundred nineteen
fifty finance
how long have you been living like that
uh well probably about three four years
my husband was laid off after working
for a company for 20 years
and he had a drastic
reduction in and pay with you know the
current job so we just
glad to have a job basically just make
you know make the best of what you can
do so
well as you've noticed your budget's
tight right yeah
yeah that's the problem
i mean you're what we call house poor
yeah
and uh so your house payment is
is two thousand bucks and your take home
pays five thousand right
right okay
and so it's 40
is that right is that what i'm doing i'm
doing that yeah about 44.
yeah 40 of your take-home pay is your
house payment
so the problem is you don't have money
to do anything else
that's that's the issue that's the only
reason we give the guideline
is we want you to be able to invest for
retirement for your kids college
i want to be able to save up and pay
cash for the next car and
you don't have any money by the time you
do this budget it's it's just all going
to this house
am i missing something no
uh we have we have money in the bank and
my husband we have a 401k
and a few other areas of things saved
but um and i've taken a part-time job to
try to
help supplement a little bit but i just
wonder if there's anything other than
what i'm doing to to try to rectify a
situation
that you would suggest and um do you
have to stay there stacy
i'm sorry why do you have to stay in the
house
uh no don't have to stay in the house
so have y'all considered or have a
conversation about maybe maybe it's time
to downsize until we can get back to our
income so we could be in a
at least a healthier more comfortable
situation
until we can get back on our feet
uh no we haven't discussed that i could
i could suggest it and
um bring it up and it's always a
never hurts always a good thing to try
and it never does
here's the thing
it's not a problem for 10 months right
for you guys it's not even been the end
of the world over the last three years
you've made it right
but eventually the strain will start to
show up
when you get ready to buy a car or when
something happens and there's no savings
or
you know you burn through your savings
and it's just there's just
if you do the written budget you get on
every dollar and lay out your plan
you and your husband sit and look at it
pay the house payment
pay the lights buy some food there's
just not a lot
left in this budget right
to do future it didn't start out that
way you can i know i know but that's
where we are today
and unless we see his income or your
income on a trajectory your household
income
on a trajectory going up you're going to
struggle
and strain and anthony's point is
is it worth it so i'm going to talk it
through and let's do the budget
sit down look at the budget together
let's start you know and say
okay because it's not an arbitrary
number we didn't just go oh
you know at 26 you're going to go broke
and at 25 of your take-home pay you're
going to be just fine
it the point is is that the more money
going to the house
the less money there is for life yeah
and life includes retirement
ongoing it recruits saving for kids
college it includes
vacations and christmas and replacement
of cars and couches
and these kinds of things and it's very
difficult to do that in the budget that
you're giving me
yeah and i've done budgets for 30 years
so i kind of in my head
instantaneously know what you're going
to find when you do what i'm asking you
to do and lay this out on paper
and i think you hit it on the head dave
but then also had a conversation about
okay
how much longer do we want to stay in
this situation and is selling the house
a good option it may not be a good
option i don't know the full situation
but if it is a good option they may have
some equity there they can put back in
the savings and go buy
something a little bit smaller a little
bit more affordable for where they are
now
and then we teach as your income goes
back up then you can make some
adjustments
uh from there yeah and if you sit down
look at it and you go okay these three
things are going to happen and our
income is going to go up in the next 14
months
then you stay if you like the house yeah
that's not a problem the point is if
it's going to stay
pretty much stagnant in this situation
for the next five to 10 years
it's going to be a strain yeah that's
the whole reasoning behind it stacy yeah
so you guys can make that call
a good question we appreciate you
joining us